[Música]
economía en directo américa de francés
24 me acompaña en el estudio louis en
mentes uriz y louis es bienvenido buena
mañana de miércoles vamos por supuesto a
iniciar hablando de este conflicto en
ucrania que cumple ya hoy seis meses y
ha tenido por supuesto una alta
repercusión en la vida económica de
todos los países involucrados así es
raúl no sólo de estas dos naciones en
conflictos sino de todo el globo porque
lo primero que se debe tener en cuenta
es que estas dos naciones que están en
esta lucha bélica son importantes
exportadores de materias primas
hidrocarburos sobre todo en el caso de
rusia y de alimentos para gran parte del
mundo el conflicto ha tenido tal
repercusión en la economía que
organismos como el fondo monetario
internacional han tenido que rebajar sus
pronósticos de crecimiento para este año
pero entendiendo un poco cómo estaban
las economías de ambos países el previo
al conflicto podemos evaluar que rusia
de acuerdo con datos del observatorio de
complejidad económica en el año 2020 fue
la economía número 11 en términos del
producto interno bruto la número 13 en
cuanto a exportaciones totales fue el
puesto 21 en importaciones totales y
números 70 en economía en cuanto al pib
per cápita además fue la número 43 en
cuanto a economía más compleja esto
según el índice de complejidad económica
por su parte ucrania como es bien sabido
es uno de los principales países que
exporta trigo de hecho junto a rusia
concentra en un tercio de los
suministros mundiales de este producto
además la nación produce y exporta a
otros cereales como el girasol también
el aceite de girasol por citar algunos
en 2021 los últimos datos de la nación
reflejaron un crecimiento económico de
3,4 puntos porcentuales un salto
significativo si tomamos en cuenta la
contracción de 38 % que sufrió durante
el año 2020 adicionalmente registró una
inflación
en 10 puntos porcentuales esto significa
el doble que el año 2020 además de una
tasa de desempleo de 89 % pero el
conflicto ha generado preocupación
especialmente entre las naciones de la
unión europea dado que una crisis
energética podría avecinarse esto
producto un corte en el suministro de
gas y petróleo ruso de hecho la
situación ha disparado los precios de la
energía en gran parte de europa y el
bloque de los 27 entre tanto la
capacidad agrícola de ucrania se ha
visto mermada y de acuerdo con la
plataforma apk informe la cosecha de
granos entre los que se encuentran el
trigo y el maíz podría rondar entre los
52,5 y 55,4 millones de toneladas para
este año esto es una reducción
considerable si comparamos la cifra
récord de 86 millones que fueron
exportados en el año que fueron
producidas en el año 2021
entretanto ya hablando de lo que es la
previsión económica
y rusia para este año estaría según
datos del gobierno en 42 puntos
porcentuales una cifra que está baja del
78 que había ofrecido el ministerio de
economía hace unos tres meses en cuanto
a ucrania esta economía podría
contraerse un 33,4 por ciento según los
datos del banco nacional de esa nación
bueno luis gracias por hacernos digamos
este recuento económico hoy 24 de agosto
cuando se marcan 6 meses del inicio de
esta invasión pero cambiamos ahora de
tema hablemos de un nuevo escándalo que
se acude a las oficinas de twitter un
tema que usted le apasiona me aproximo y
en este caso tiene que ver con un ex
jefe de seguridad que acusó a la
compañía de engaño y negligencia en
medio de la batalla legal de la empresa
con hilos moss pero conozcamos más en el
siguiente informe de rafael pérez
negligencia en twitter peter mod go ex
jefe de seguridad de la compañía acusó a
la red social de engañar sobre la
seguridad cibernética y la erradicación
de las cuentas falsas la revelación
podría traer problemas legales y
financieros a la plataforma que demandó
al multimillonario y los moscos para
obligarlo a consumar su oferta de compra
avivando así uno de los temas por los
que el magnate frenó la adquisición de
la compañía los perfiles ficticios o
spam la organización legal we shall
blower y confirmó la información what's
it just engabao match y es lo
interesante de match es que es muy
respetado tanto en las comunidades de
piratas informáticos que son bastante
antiautoritarias como en la comunidad de
inteligencia de eeuu ha trabajado para
la cia
darpa con la casa blanca varias veces
entonces sabe lo que está hablando
el millonario sudafricano publicó un
tweet en el que sin mencionar al
informante le hace una sutil referencia
otra de las revelaciones fue el supuesto
compromiso de twitter de implementar
medidas más estrictas para proteger la
seguridad y la privacidad de sus
usuarios peter mosaico fue despedido a
principios de 2022 y no fue hasta julio
que presentó sus inquietudes ante la
comisión de bolsa y valores de eeuu con
las revelaciones las acciones de twitter
cayeron en un 6% este martes dejamos a
un lado a twitter para vernos para
venirnos a nuestra región de américa
latina y el caribe luis méndez vamos a
colombia porque el presidente de ese
país gustavo petro anunció que dejará
para el año próximo su proyecto de una
reforma laboral es una de las reformas
que plantea el gobierno de gustavo petro
también está la reforma tributaria pero
en cuanto a la reforma laboral el
mandatario indicó que será discutida
antes con empresarios y trabajadores
esto con la intención de llegar al
mejoramiento del clima laboral de
acuerdo con el ejecutivo desde este
momento y hasta los meses de diciembre o
enero se llevarán a cabo las
conversaciones la reforma entre otras
cosas busca mejorar para los
trabajadores pago de horas nocturnas a
partir de las seis de la tarde equidad
salarial entre hombres y mujeres y
también finalizar con los contratos de
prestación de servicios también en la
búsqueda de una mayor estabilidad en
cada uno de los puestos de trabajo bueno
vamos ahora con los indicadores
económicos louis hay que señalar que las
acciones han estado mostrando números
mixtos tanto en europa como en asia
donde en estos momentos hay operaciones
por ejemplo en asia los mercados de
japón y de china terminaron a la baja
durante del día de hoy todavía siguen
incertidumbre en cuanto a presiones
inflacionarias por ejemplo hoy se dieron
los datos de inflación de singapur yo
estos impactaron también los mercados
asiáticos en cuanto a disminuir la
cantidad de operaciones y por ello
también se vieron afectados por otro
lado también en las operaciones europeas
que se están desarrollando en estos
momentos ha mostrado números mixtos con
alzas en
alemania y francia pero caída en
reinounido cifra el día louis tiene que
ver en este caso con los 33 barcos que
ya han logrado zarpar desde ucrania con
alimentos esto luego que se cumplen
meses de la firma del acuerdo entre la
onu y turquía para poder sacar la
cantidad de granos represados en los
puertos ucranianos
graciasluis como siempre por toda la
información económica más adelante más
economía y pasamos a saludar un maleza
para hablar de deportes